je sais que c'est le moment où je suis
censé vous réconforter hallucinations
apparition appelez ça comme vous voulez
nous n'avons jamais eu autant de morts
cela peut changer une ville pour
toujours
on t'a donné un don pour une raison
c'est l'occasion d'en servir pour elle
yb est ces choses dans nos têtes on doit
pas croire ce qu'on voit là on voit bien
garde ils sont croatie ils sont en
colère
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant il
faut trouver un moyen de les combattre
on est piégé nous défendons notre île
peu importe ce qu'il a en coupe
et ô grand jamais de nous rendre
je ne nourris serait quoi dans la maison
de dieu quand une dame veut s'en aller
mais qu'est ce mais qu'elle se retrouve
comme piéger cette dame va s'en prendre
aux vivants